the system especially in the UK is an
absolute scam in terms of finances it is
rigged so that you and me are poor and
let me tell you exactly how this is
happening and I think this is going to
get worse and worse and worse I did a
prediction back in 2016 and I said that
10 of the UK were Rich 10 were poor and
80 were comfortable and what I said is
as in 10 years Time by 2026 there will
be no more comfortable there will either
be rich or they'll be poor and the poor
will work for the rich and the rich will
do what they want and what is happening
is that is beginning to come true right
now because salaries aren't going up
salaries have hardly gone up since I
made that prediction like six years ago
so salaries are staying the same but
everything else is going up in value
rents are going up house prices are
going up gas is going up Broadband
travel do you know that just travel
alone if you want to get a flight in the
last 18 months travel has gone up by 300
so how can we afford to live live on two
three thousand pounds a month when the
average rent is a thousand the average
the bills are three or four hundred and
they're tripling bills and the answer is
we can't we can't live on a normal job
it is becoming impossible so comfortable
people are going to become poor unless
they learn how to become rich what are
the rich doing right now well the rich
are buying land and investing in
property because if you own property and
then things go up the cost of wood goes
up which it has it's tripled and you own
stuff then that's a good thing if you
own stuff and things go up rents go up
it's good because you own houses and
when rents go up you get richer so the
rich are buying everything Bill Gates
owns more Farmland in the United States
of America than anybody else so the rich
are buying lands because they know that
land will go up in value over time the
banks are buying land the banks are
buying properties Lloyd's Bank said last
year that their their goal is to become
the biggest private landlords in Britain
that's scary you know what it's scary
because when you go to Lloyds Bank and
you ask them for a loan and they say
what for and you say to invest in
property they say that's too risky don't
do that leave that to us they literally
will not give you a loan to go and buy a
house but they will give you a loan to
go on holiday they will give you a loan
to get married you know why that is
because the lenders want us to be in bad
debt so we cannot afford to pay back the
interest so they can charge us interest
on the interest and if we don't pay it
back then they will take away our house
even though the money that they give us
is not real if you get a loan from A
bank there's no transferring of wealth
or Metals it is digits on a screen but
if you can't pay back the interest and
the interest on the interest then they
will take away something very real
namely your house because that is what
they want they want land they want
houses and the rich are getting richer
and richer and richer while the poor are
getting poorer and poorer and poorer I
work in food banks and 10 years ago if
people will come into food banks to get
free food and clothes you know who will
come in who homeless people on the
streets now you know who comes to get
food nurses that is a tragedy at school
they brainwash us to be good boys and
girls and to comply and get good exams
and then we get good exams and go to UNI
and get into the rat race and climb the
corporate ladder and even if you get to
the top of the corporate ladder you
realize you climbed the wrong ladder
even if you win the rat race you realize
you are still a rat I dropped out of
school age 16 and knew nothing about
money because they deliberately do not
put Financial education in the school
curriculums so that we are workers they
deliberately do not teach kids about the
difference between assets and
liabilities active income and passive
income compound interest how to run a
business they don't teach it in school
and that's something that I'm fighting
against right now I refuse to be a
whinger about this I refuse to say
that's terrible the rich the elites
isn't it terrible and be poor I refuse
to do that and that is why I have
educated myself and had mentors and had
trainers and have become a
multi-millionaire and I believe that
when you get to the top of the mountain
you have a responsibility to pull others
up with you becoming rich is not luck it
is clearly a skill set in the same way
as learning to drive if you drive it's
not like oh you got lucky no you just
learn to drive being rich is the same I
have proven this over and over and over
when I've done Financial Freedom
challenges whereas a social experiment
I've stripped myself from everything
including my bank account and my
identity and I've become financially
free all over again time and time again
from scratch my videographers that watch
me go oh my goodness and then they leave
and go do the same thing it'll be
tempting for me to hold back the secrets
from my staff I've got 46 members of
Staff because they keep becoming
financially free themselves and keep
leaving but then I would be no different
from the large corporations in the elite
where they keep the Secrets close to the
chest and keep people dumbed down my
YouTube videos keep getting taken down
and I've been threatened by YouTube
multiple times that they might ban my
account literally for what for talking
about money look for talking about the
help to buy schemes for messing with the
banks because sometimes I go to the bank
and I'll say can I make a withdrawal and
they'll say how much and I'll say 2
million and they'll say we don't have it
and I'll expose them and this is stuff
that does Russell feathers and I've told
you in the past that my YouTube video
I've set up a whole another account I
don't know whether this account will
even stay so I have done something which
I think will be an absolute Game Changer
not just to my students but also to my
subscribers on YouTube I have for the
last three years been working
relentlessly on putting together a book
now this book is an incred this is a
this is like a Bible type length book
okay huge and this includes everything I
know about property
is
condensed into this book and this book
is something that I want you to have in
your household I want you to give to
your kids it literally is a cross
between Rich Dad Poor Dad with the
philosophy
the autobiography of my story and how I
dropped out of school and how I've
become worth 20 million pounds but also
the exact how to it is a copy and paste
guide to getting seriously rich and it
needs to be in your hands so I've got it
on Amazon now just for the record in
case you're thinking oh Samuel's just
doing a big sales pitch I literally make
okay when these books are Amazon you get
paperback hardback Kindle I literally
make about one or two pounds every time
Amazon sells a book so I am not doing
this to try and get rich this took me
two and a half years to write it is
absolutely everything A to Z that I know
about business property investing into a
book The reason I'm doing this is not
because I'm trying to create a big bank
account for myself it's because I'm
trying to create a big Legacy I want a
statue when I'm gone okay and I think
this book is going to really help with
with passing on the legacy of what I've
done this is my way of when I'm at the
Mountaintop pulling people up through
this book so I would highly recommend
getting it on Amazon I think it's like
this is this is 14 pound 99
um you can get the Kindle version for 10
pounds or 9.99 but here's what I'm
saying as well I don't want you to just
read the book I want to Mentor you so I
can't Mentor every single person that
gets the book but what I am going to be
doing is if you leave a review of the
book once you've read it
and then just share it on your Instagram
story and tag me I'm going to be taking
one person and I'm going to be mentoring
them and doing a Financial Freedom
challenge with them this is going to be
9 000 pounds worth of training you're
going to get access to all of my
investors you're going to get access to
all of the contracts that you need which
are worth thousands of pounds and I'm
going to be mentoring you so all you got
to do is leave a review of the book and
then share it on my Instagram story and
I'll be taking one person as winner of
that but just for leaving it with you
just for getting the book and leaving a
review and sharing it like I'm going to
be giving you an invitation to come and
spend one day with me where I'm going to
be training you getting to know you so
this is my gift to my subscribers this
is my gift to the world I hope that it
changes things I know that it will I
know that you have a choice of being
rich or poor because having a job and
just following the status quo of the
system does not cut it anymore and this
is going to be your way out so as I say
you've only got 10 pounds left in the
world go on Amazon get the Kindle
version and review it I can't wait to
work with you I hope you enjoyed the
book I've spent two and a half years
slaving away making this happen and I
will leave a link and Amazon link below
in the description stay blessed get rich
Let's do this together
[Music]